hi there reject nation
I'm Greg Alba and I'm John Humphrey
we're gonna watch the trailer for Once
Upon a Deadpool today before we going to
that I want to say thank you to everyone
who's been following us in the Stardust
and way over there we have over 7.5 k
followers thank you very much we do you
30 second reaction reviews for any film
TV show or trailer a lot of them are
micro sketches the app is free to
download free to use so download it and
use it today go check out john bailey on
this let's do this
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's funny because it's rated pg-13 for
practically all the same reasons it's
rated R it has slightly lesser burden
what I imagine is that they're probably
I mean obviously like with that Update
joke and you know all this stuff that
they have a Fred Savage going on that
they probably shot a lot of new footage
for this where they're gonna be poking a
lot of fun at the fact that it's pg-13
when I first heard about this I was like
that sounds like the stupidest gimmick
ever yeah who's gonna want a pg-13
Deadpool now that were you know getting
more footage for it and remembering what
Deadpool is like I'm like you know what
this is probably gonna be pretty funny
and they're probably gonna poke a lot of
fun at the fact that it's all censored
and everything like that make fun of
this give me something special yeah yeah
I guess I hadn't thought of the fact
they would probably take this as an
opportunity to do something particularly
fun or wacky with it and I'm sure that
there's gonna be a lot of stuff that's
very obvious like you know the kind of
joke we're obviously alluding to
something raunchy but doing something
very innocuous to heighten yeah that's
like I'm sure they did a bunch of those
kinds of things and you know to see this
like Fred Savage Princess Bride thing
going on I wonder if that's gonna be the
wrap around somehow if it's gonna
imagine oh go throughout the rail you
ripoff yeah movie basically it just
seems like a great time man it was
actually like a really talented director
a lot of people don't realize that man
he brought Wizards of Waverly Place in
the Disney Channel life people want to
read the description box for this leans
Fox has been asking for a pg-13
basically since it started in 2006 Ryan
Reynolds thought deadline I've said no
since 2006 now this one time I said yes
on two conditions
first a portion of proceeds has to go to
charity second I want to kidnap Fred
Savage
the second condition took some
explaining and Fred Savage will draw
Reynolds and new scenes for once upon a
time of Deadpool and homage to the
savages storm rolled in 1987 bedtime
story classic The Princess Bride federal
marked well my participation in the film
was anything but voluntary I'm happy to
learn that fudge cancer will be the
beneficiary of the shameless cash-grab
[Laughter]
every ticket sold $1 will go to the
charity fudge cancer previously known as
[ __ ] cancer who have graciously changed
her name to be more pg-13 friendly for
the 12 days of Once Upon a Deadpool's
release this is really fascinating yeah
man I mean Deadpool - did it make as
much money as Deadpool won but it's not
like the movie was a flop by any stretch
you know there's a very dedicated
fanbase of people who love that movie
anyway yeah yeah and I preferred it over
the first one so you know I'm really
curious to see what we have in store
with this specifically they are taking
something I initially rolled my eyes so
hard at and now I really really would
yeah it did with the charity angles nice
thing I really hope that is true well
it's like the nice thing is is that you
know it's gonna be more than just some
silly I mean it is kind of a cash grab
of course but just thinking about all
like I thought Deadpool 2 was more
violent than the first one and you know
like there's a lot of vulgarity and
everything like that of course they had
what are they going to do what are they
gonna do to replace that with because
you know they're not just gonna censor
it they're gonna do yeah and to make fun
of it and replace it especially if
they're gonna put it out in the theaters
they're gonna take advantage of that oh
yeah totally I guess my best guess would
be that they probably went back and
changed what they could just digitally
or whatever yeah maybe if it's like
changing the color of blood or so yeah
and then yeah they probably went back in
Schad just a number of all the bits that
wouldn't work with just a little
tinkering yeah are you guys excited to
see it once you comment below tell me if
you're gonna spend some money in between
all the Hubble a little livable ooh it's
Christmas take your favorite kid or do
you wish elite a battle angels coming
out instead and before we wrap this up I
want to give a patron the day shout out
to a man named - Raj Krishna on all the
way on the East Coast
Raj is a very very friendly gentleman
who recently were talking a lot about
our love for certain kind of music and
everything in this month it was Diwali I
didn't know what that
is actually and we have a large Indian
subscriber fanbase actually if you
haven't seen that episode of the offices
and how I forgot what it was Diwali is
the festival of lights which is
celebrated every autumn in the northern
hemisphere spring in the southern
hemisphere symbolizes the spiritual
victory of light over darkness good over
evil and knowledge over ignorant I want
to say thank you to Niraj krishna for
following us in our patreon and i hope
you have a happy thanksgiving you were
telling me how great it's gonna be and
to all who celebrate Diwali happy Diwali
we're so late to that I apologize it's
the thought that counts anyway you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell hey check us out
and start us a free download free to use
I like free stuff does God